ein thema geht gerade leider unter vor
lauter corona das lobbyregister seit
zehn jahren verspricht die
bundesregierung schon ein verbindliches
lobby-register zehn jahre
aktueller stand ist droht schon wieder
zu scheitern wohlgemerkt ist ganz
wichtig lobbyismus an sich ist völlig in
ordnung gehört dazu aber wir bürger
müssen schon erfahren welche lobbyisten
welchen einfluss auf welche
entscheidungen nehmen transparenz hat
außerdem sollten natürlich alle
lobbyisten gleich guten zugang zur
politik haben und jetzt raten sie doch
mal bei wem letzteres sogar nicht klappt
hallo zusammen wussten sie wie viel zeit
und arbeit notwendig sind um einen bund
möhren zu erzeugen was meinen sie hallo
ich möchte mit ihnen über möhren
sprechen
egal was die frau sagt ist klingt immer
nach homeshopping foodwatch hat die
möhren ministerin übrigens jetzt
verklagt man will sie zwingen für einen
bestimmten monat alle ihre lobby
kontakte offenzulegen
dazu gab es neulich schon mal eine
kleine anfrage der grünen und ein teil
der antworten könnte die bevölkerung
verunsichern
in der vergangenheit konnte gezeigt
werden dass julia klöckner sich
hauptsächlich mit vertretern der
wirtschaft also mit lobbyisten aus
wirtschaftsverbänden und von unternehmen
getroffen hat und fast gar nicht mit
verbraucherschutzverbänden oder
umweltschutzverbänden ja natürlich nicht
die riechen streng 2018 hat sich gärtner
unter anderem mit dem schokoriegel
konzern maß getroffen immer wieder mit
bauernverbänden aber was einzelgespräche
angeht wohl 0 x mit umwelt- oder
verbraucher einiges auf eine art
verstehe ich ja ich meine die einnahmen
präsentkörbe mit wurst dabei die
foodwatch typen immer nur schlechte
laune und unterstellung frau klöckner
ist als ministerin neutral und setzt
sich natürlich genauso für bauern ein
wie für sagen wir mal uns verbraucher
selbst anzapfen ja klar
natürlich bin ich lobbyistin für land
hätte ach so ja klar
bei dem satz haben sich viele ferkel vor
wut selber kastriert aber es war
immerhin ehrlich lobbyisten der bauern
und das stimmt ja sie hat gerade erst
die neue pflanzenschutzmittel verordnung
um anderthalb jahre verzögert
stichwort insekten sterben sie hat dafür
gesorgt dass die pfandpflicht für milch
wenn überhaupt frühestens 2024 kommt und
nicht schon wie geplant in diesem jahr
und und und tatsächlich hat die frau
klöckner eine ganz harte tür da kommst
du als lobbyist wirklich nur rein wenn
du zum beispiel nachweisen kannst dass
du für den bauernverband arbeitest und
natürlich alle die für den sc arbeiten
das ja klar ist ja logisch
will sagen ein verbindliches
lobby-register wäre schön nach zehn
jahren streit es droht aber zu scheitern
unter anderem bei cdu und csu nicht
wollen dass es auch für die beamten und
mitarbeiter in den ministerien gilt die
aber und jetzt kommt im
gesetzgebungsprozess die eigentliche
arbeit machen
union und spd haben sich verhaken jetzt
kommt vielleicht gar nicht ganz kurz gab
es wissen sie mal hoffnung letzten
sommer als philipp am tor durch falsche
freunde auf die schiefe bahn geraten ist
da hat sogar die union gesagt hier muss
was passieren
jetzt schläft alles wieder ein was sagt
man dazu
0 weitere haken beim gros gesetzentwurf
er basiert überraschung viel zu sehr auf
freiwilligkeit der lobbyist die
lobbyisten soll eintragen mit wie viel
aufwand und budget seinen laden notiert
aber wenn er oder sie da keinen bock
drauf haben wissen sie was dann passiert
und wissen sie was die schärfste
sanktion ist wenn man sich für die
option entscheidet die auskunft nicht zu
erteilen
die verweigerung eines hausausweise
sprich der freie zugang zur kantine des
parlaments wird verweigert meine damen
und herren
das ist hart junge junge also hätte ich
gedacht dass die so weit gehen meine
transparenz gut und schön aber das geht
ja schon in den bereich
menschenrechtsverletzung der bundestag
lange der perfekte ort für hinterzimmer
mauscheleien
skrupellose lobby schreckten nicht
einmal davor zurück unschuldige kinder
in ihrer dreckigen geschäfte mit
reinzuziehen
aber damit ist jetzt schluss
wer nicht alles offenlegt in unserem
lobby register
ihr könnt mich mal verliert seinem
hausausweis sein
das können wir nicht machen doch nächste
woche ist jägerschnitzel woche ohne dich
das neue lobby register ab jetzt essen
wir die alle selbst als tough gesunder
lobbyismus geht nur transparent heute
war in berlin wieder wirecard
untersuchungsausschuss sie können einmal
googeln wie viele ex politiker für diese
verbrecher lobbyiert haben oder hier
anderes aktuelles lobby beispiel corona
helfen wer die kriegt und wenn ich die
autoindustrie kriegt 5 milliarden
staatshilfen corona irgendwie und dann
meldet vw gerade zehn milliarden gewinn
für 2020
der lobbyismus fordere ich muss endlich
raus aus der schmuddelecke hier heimlich
gedrehte bilder von einer illegalen
karnevalsparty
sie kommen zu sitzungen unseres garde
war meilen stiefeln lobbyisten ein
fröhliches la vie lobby führen heute das
trecker juden die mit abstand beste
ministerin in der rog
er wolle ja kein witz apropos julia
klöckner eine laudatio einreihen
willst du einfluss in berlin bei ihr
bekommst du einen termin bei winzer
wunschpaarung jeder von uns war dass ich
auch ne du nicht du hippie verpiss dich
hoch julian ein bisschen schwärzel schon
macht sie die top-gesetzte der laie
fragt sich was kann die sich jedoch
schlechter als der steuer an die davon
wegen war die frau alles berühmten hat
die säule stehen im kasten stand noch
acht jahren
gott sei dank
im kaufland spot beim boss von
erstligist shops ist sie die beste
ob es ums amt zuckersteuer das wird doch
alles viel zu teuer
das stoppt uns juden stets adrett und um
die kinder bleiben
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten
einfach anklicken märz gut los los du
scheiße fährt